[Music]
[Music]
okay so quick question before we start
did everyone get a chance to either get
this lap notebook or to get home to get
that rebound anyone want to take a break
yeah okay so quick question
[Music]
okay great this won't be too boring for
you so today we're not covered we're
gonna cover what it is is what each and
will actually cover you but it turns out
the math is easy part these for the part
part is setting up and I just have this
this project with my 3ds job that says
who they are in common sense because
oftentimes that's the most important
part of your a t-test not these guys
okay so and so so so you see click on
the link and in this case we're able to
say a little bit more people tidal age
so that must be the middle title and
going forward you have one that's
basically what the ESS oh I might
previous back before between to be a
scientist who's actually do me a
computational web I'm sorry so I view
this almost elated prep trial where you
have a placebo and treatment and you
give some people want some people the
other and see what's on much like so
that's what an a/b test is but what's
really important is to figure out
winning actually grow great to know it's
very trendy to a t-test everything
that's wrong so the first thing you need
to do is actually trying to make a
decision this might seem obvious but
it's actually not well times when people
are a t-test mean they've already
decided that they want to go with
version V and they kind of just want
proof for that he was a very kind of
trying to cover their own access for
their process that is a recipe for
disaster
test me because it's going to push you
towards making bad statistic incisions
trying to justify yourself it's a waste
of your company so any justice move
perfect when he actually might go with
either A or B um the other thing is
important that kind of ties to actually
making a decision is it shouldn't be
hard to make the a new year so in the
example we used before it's easy to come
up with two different titles in as
little to be shown after one thousand
yet another scenario where people often
trade is building feature so they have
some sort of product the product kinds
of age right now is routine a and the
product is some new feature is version B
if there's some easy ways for the new
teacher and it's not a long work then
it's Rachel run any tests but if you had
to put tons and tons of working to build
your new feature you're not gonna be
willing to have those and so you're
gonna have this problem there's all
these institutional momentum behind
version B and so your results don't
really matter so what you generally want
to do is have your varies and that easy
something that you do so a good example
of this is rather than testing out the
new feature to test out some sort of
proxy right so me what what you want to
do instead for instance I worked on an
a/b test once where we're considering um
having a new offering for Emily was an
educational product many when I have
quizzes India and so when they get for
the evening test was rather than
actually building out local quizzes
bought product indicating a really long
time
they had a pop up at the end that said
would you be interested in taking a quiz
and they had in the movie just a
different pop up that has some other
message and they saw how likely it will
work a clip
and so in that case you didn't have to
put that kind of effort in so it was
much easier to test new people um and
then my legs little one that's not
really obvious is you should be test if
there is several risk of harm to your
users and customers so this was actually
a real situation and I was working on an
educational product that was homework
for students and we had two different
algorithms that would actually change
the homework that was assigned to
different students and they wanted to
eat me tested within a single classroom
that isn't ethical no no because it
means that you could have some kids
who's feeding a hardier homework
assignment others actually prove it
right or you could you have some
students received an assignment not
useful in that case you can do what's
called block randomization where you can
say okay maybe rather than having it
randomize compete with your student
level maybe we'll encouragement it at
the liberal classes to at least everyone
who's graded on the curve is getting the
same assignment and even then you have
to get employment of the teachers um
another version of this is our customer
become to your business if you think
there is a chance that one of your
various would like take your product
me only not to half of your audience
maybe maybe you want to do some sort
very Control Houston
so these are the three things to keep in
mind when deciding on to AP test
okay so now I would like you guys to
open your notebook there are three
questions at the top of it I'd like to
all to turn to a neighbor introduce
yourself so now to do it maybe cut this
how my Amazon use it how my equites use
it and mostly how my five minutes
and at the end of looked here and it was
to share a house Kate would like to
choose DHS so we could be
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow okay yeah so when in that what is
your control room who you're targeting
the outside or what like you're using
Facebook I just put around yeah okay so
that'd be really so so we do that's a
really great great example and I
actually I'm going to run with that and
use that in our next our next goal all
right
anyone else yeah after I hope we use
maybe best to validate or offices on our
search ranking algorithms awesome that
is one of the the key part and we're
actually going to talk a little bit
about algorithms of different algorithms
in the next section I would you guys
have been sustaining my family okay well
so we're gonna we're actually going to
talk a little bit about both of those
examples okay so the next section is
what do I actually need to run in a
t-test so a thing that happens a whole
lot to you to data professionals is you
start a new job and they say we never
run an a/b test before we really want to
do it tell us how to do it anyhow Matias
most scientists know a lot about hi
analyze the EEG test but actually a data
scientist alone can't set up an a/b test
usually but it's helpful to know sort of
what you need to ask for to be able to
run it so we're going to cover three
things that you need if great more
metrics and then some sanity checks to
run the metrics are a matías data
professionals are really responsible for
everything else were mostly sort of
providing that checklist for other
people and again that purveyor of common
sense so frameworks framework and how we
actually show a versus in two different
people
in order for our a/b to support we have
to actually have that capability
so one of the easiest ways we can do
this is if somehow you've already
reduced your products that has a t-test
built in as a functionality so for
instance if you're using the email
marketing campaign software like Xavier
or MailChimp or any of those other
things a lot of times they'll actually
have a set for maybe tests where you can
either have two different email subject
lines or two different kinds of email
tests and it has everything built in
it'll do the click through rate support
usually it's open rates and also in
application
system so anything that generates
obviously have used a cue or hand oh
those usually have any testing settings
we say only sure this pop up to happen
people so that could be really helpful
now obviously this doesn't work for
everything so another option so the
classic AP test is we have some sort of
aesthetic change to our website we have
two different layouts or even two
different colors for a button a lot of
times if we want to run something like
that we really have about change to HTML
and how page is displayed
there are purchased frameworks go
million years so these are Google
optimized Unbounce Optimizely basically
Google Ad testing framework and you'll
see all of them now these are expensive
and active as a company you choose to
pay for them but you can basically give
it your website URL tell it what you
want change and usually easy to set up
and you don't have to do a whole
engineering working on now final thing
is if you want to test something in a
custom way so this is either tend to be
a if you have something very specific
you want to do in terms of turning over
if you're testing an algorithm like
broke up in this case you're not
probably not going to be able to use
third-party software you actually have
to build something in-house
this is art this you're gonna have to
devote an engineering team reporter to
actually build an a/b test framework you
probably don't want to do this unless
you plan on doing a lot of AP testing
but the sort of website do devote that
energy you have a lot more options so
one thing that we'll cover a little bit
later well really cool cover and then
I'll save three sentences on it is
Bayesian and investing that only works
generally if you have your own framework
set up now the other reason that this
can be really helpful is targeting so
for instance even you don't want to just
completely randomly assign people to
groups if you want to say something like
I will only want to a t-test on users
with this set of parameters
you might have to concentrate okay so
once we have a way of displaying a and B
now we actually need something to
measure so if we go back to that little
chart that I'm in and in here we know
why asked we need some way of Spain
which is better able me oh so PHP
consider when choosing a metric your
metric has to be measurable with your
Franklin so for instance if you decided
that you're using an email marketing
platform it's probably not going to be
easy for you to measure things like
dollar amounts that people purchase on
your website because that can be logged
in a completely different system then if
your email marketing software so um then
these others was her to commence on the
one hand whatever metric issues so in a
lot of cases um so I don't know what MPs
is neck rotors for yeah can you give us
a definition yeah it's basically it is
an empirically validated way of saying
how popular your product is it's a
little pop-up question how likely are
you to refer this product to a friend
and then a scale from from one to ten
and there's a special way of measuring
its we use it because it's very common
across the industry and you can find and
guess values for different industries to
be able to say like okay I brought them
in line with my competitors but anyway
and kiss is very very generic mentoring
so it's probably not a good method to
pair with changing the color of crepe we
don't really expect those two things to
be related and it's much more likely
that you see a different and yes that
there's some other compounding factor
now on the other hand you have the
consideration that what a metric that's
actually important to our business so
for instance a probably pretty easy to
measure the amount of time that people
spend hovering over buttons
colors they talk about action so we're
always trying to balance those two
things we want to metric it's relevant
to business they're also build meant to
whatever it is that we're testing so
common metrics that people use
click-through rate is by far the most
common just that percentage of people
who click on an email or dollar amount
purchased can be another one email open
rate each reduces drink and then
satisfaction can be something so fast
actually so he shared with us the idea
that a survey can be a metric so you
might have some sort of a question that
you asked people after they've seen two
different versions of your product or
your website and that can be your metric
how people respond to that question okay
so finally there are a set of sanity
checks that again is it strictly your
job as a data scientist - yeah but it's
good to have a back of your and these
are all real publicizing tests so number
one make sure you're a t-test is
actually showing both a and B I've
actually seen this happen where one
piece of code overrode another piece of
code and only the main metric pepper
show um you also want to check to make
sure that you get the correct slit so if
you're expecting a 50 split 50-50 split
of a and B but that's actually showing
up or I'll turn it to you if you're
expecting 90% HIV this actual action is
showing up the way I'd usually
accomplish this is before the time
starts make sure that if I open up some
incognito windows that I've seen both
variants eventually and then once the
test starts have some sort of advanced
board that I can refresh and be checking
and it just counts how many people saw a
and how many people saw another thing I
want to check is can the same person see
multiple variants and get that maybe a
product this
so the classic example where this is
really got is suppose you're testing new
to be depressing test and some people
are going to see 10% discount some
people are going to get 20% discount
people are going to be kind of upset if
on two different days they see three
different races the classic example is
people you're really really mad we're
losing that airline prices change in
other cases again in the case of like
the button color it might not really
matter if the same person can see your
branch about 10 different games so
there's a couple ways you can control
rates one thing is we can make sure that
the same ip address always sees the same
variant the problem with that is that
people might be losing both on their
laptop and on their phone those of you
to different IP address is that your
problem another way people will control
for this is if your product has some
sort of login only assigning the
variants and and displaying after people
objects that we need to make sure that
the same identity always sees the same
thing and then finally you can make
randomness up here these are all part of
the game so really common example that
is you've ever gone to a website and it
says like you know spin the wheel to see
what discount you get that can get used
to running because that way it's
expected that you might see another
thing that's really important is to make
sure that you're actually collecting the
data that you need capital in your Metro
so that both means collecting the actual
people it also means knowing if someone
saw the a variant or the B marriage so
that we give the problem when you have
one system that's running the ad test
and deciding pieces and E and a
different system that's blocked in the
metric and you don't have a common key
to try on so you don't have like
Newton's alrighty that's the same as we
build systems so that's really what you
want to make sure that you can track
both of those things and then finally
it's good to have a single person who is
sort of in charge of monitoring that
could be you or that quick
the manager first not one but there
should be some sort of dashboard and
someone whose job is to refresh it and
check on it real story I actually had a
product manager who was supposed to be
in charge go on vacation believe that we
launched the AP test and didn't realize
until like halfway through that it is so
som someone should be in charge someone
and in particular if there's any reason
why you might want to stop the agent as
early so for instance if you're doing a
pricing test and it becomes clear that
twenty more people are buying as bottom
line is a company where vehicle stop or
in the case of no we're going to go to
and there are three examples three data
sets and each one of them has a so each
one of these is a possible result I
would like you all examples one two and
three 11:13 at eleven
we'll discuss what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right we have stickers from our
dancers they're very cute your job and
they say the world has made our parents
living on it unfortunately the movers
did not have any external approval
stickers for insurance all right so does
anyone want to talk about what I'd be
probably example one yes
what it doesn't accurately measure the
outcome that's exactly right so for
example one we sent a newsletter out
we've got who who saw the newsletter
what time they got we don't have whether
or not all right how about example two
what seems to be the problem with
example two only one very yes okay so
example 3 is likely for long because
this was actually a real test does
anyone want to talk about what's going
on in example exactly so say my feet can
see different different and then I want
to talk a little bit about the bonus
question number one so let's talk about
better stuff number one in number juice
no 1 if I'm sending different people
different discount if it's not
necessarily a good way to test different
price points and why might not me anyway
so this is just a psychological thing
that if people see that they're getting
a bigger discount they might be more
excited about that discount than they
would necessarily be about just the
price point without the discount so even
a you're thinking of it isn't just that
you might not want to present it that
way to your interest and then bonus
question number two is also really
important when we're talking about
discount rates is it just a question of
which
has the better purchase rate is there
something else we should eat sir
revenue exactly
so a good back-of-the-envelope way of
thinking about that one
yeah so let's assume that a thousand
people see each various we can actually
hopefully what the amount of revenue is
for each one and about how we would
actually do that in this task okay so
now that we know what maybe test in and
we've gone through our sanity test let's
talk about how we actually analyze so
originally I showed you this bar right
but we're all data people here so we
know that no bar graph is complete
without error bars and in particular we
don't know what the intervals are for
this test and whether or not they're
overlapping so for instance this case
error bars overlap each other it might
not be a real difference it might just
be statistical noise so what will be
able to do is switch between real
difference between a and B or just a
measurement error so what I want us to
do is now switch over to the notebook
and we're going to just develop an
intuition for what effects are our
results so bear with me on this
so for example for I've created a
function for you called count percent
correct so this function is going to do
is you're going to give it sample size
so that Tommy people were shown very
very feet and then the real
click-through rates for variant and very
so the rates that we would see if we
observed infinite people of our sample
size was millions and millions so and
then a number of experiments how many
times we run the so you know imagine
that we could run the a/b test not once
but a thousand times with all of the
same sample size what this function will
then tell us how many
the directionality of our observation
matches the empirical truth so for
instance good I'm here let's say we have
a relatively small sample size like 500
and let's say that our click-through
rate for any is 5% and from be a 6% so
this is being sort of empirical this is
the ground truth think we have an
infinite size sample a would have 5
percent click-through rate you would
have 6 plus 9 click-through rate B is
better than dating and then let's just
pick a really big number for a number of
experiments let's do 10,000 and so we
want to know of those 10,000 experiments
how often do we actually get that B is
better than a if we're only showing 500
people to Jerry and it would help if I
head first
ok so in this case I only see correct
directionality in 74 percent of
experiments so this means that when I
actually run my a t-test there's only a
regatta for chance that I see the
results that is reflects what the actual
record does that make sense
ok so what I like books to do is play
around with these numbers play around
different sample sizes different values
of a meet and see what happens if you
scroll down you'll actually see some map
flip-flops where you fill in either
different sample sizes different control
e of different control egg um you can
see different you can still get
different graphs and you get a sense of
what sorts of values we need to be very
confident that we actually get the
results that we expect and so this is
keeping my decisions for us to
development injuries and actually have a
frenemy because what we just want to get
a sense of what are the different things
that actually affect our accuracy let's
take until 11:30 to play
so it's basically versus and he don't
mean it's basically adding up all the
ones that were correct
okay so I'm gonna show some offs so
first thing this is probably something
that that is pretty intuitive as our
sample size gets bigger we're more
likely to get an accurate along so and
so what you can see here is that
relatively small sample sizes like 100
in each group should be wrong let me get
up to big samples like 5,000 or 10,000
were right a lot more prevalent so this
is a really important thing to keep in
mind at the certain planning stages that
you're going to eat probably relatively
large sample sizes and you don't think
you're going to get those again and even
test might not be for you we'll also in
a few minutes we're happy we'll talk
about how to actually get the exact
sample size that you need in order to
get accuracy so another thing that's
important is the difference between the
two flickering again should be somewhat
intuitive the more different and be very
answer it easier it is to detect see you
the more likely you are to be able to
detect any present their actual games so
it is way way way way better than a
you're gonna eat either you just be more
accurate or you'll need a smaller sample
size and then finally this one I think
is a little bit unintuitive but really
interesting if your event is very rare
you need a much larger sample size to
achieve such a technically much look
likely that you'll be sensitive and this
sometimes in fact what metric you want
to use so email open rates are very very
low and like athletes are pretty good
you happen to know since you do
probably where roughly clearance thank
you guys
yeah looks like a row but like it's not
at all uncommon to have less than 1%
yeah so if you have those very very rare
events it would be much harder as you
know if two rare events are different
rates whereas if you have relatives a
continent but events it's much easier to
see their difference
so generally things that happen once
you're on the website are going to be
more common and these are the things
that happen outside of your website we
could have an ad so deciding truth where
in your problem you place the metric can
really affect your image has to can make
it much easier
so as sample size increases our
sensitivity increases as we excise the
difference between increases increases
and then in the baseline metric in this
case we're gonna say look great in
Christmas presents today devices and
generally I become this as as effect
size increases the necessary sample size
increases as baseline CTR increases the
necessary sample size differences okay
so that's all fun and technically good
set up some sort of little simulation
like this and just keep plugging in
values you were to decide you're not
that's not really how we do we actually
have a more formal Franklin furnace and
it's called hypothesis test so the way
hypothesis testing works is certainly a
null hypothesis the null hypothesis is
that we assume there is no difference
between a and B and then we look at the
results of our customers say what is the
probability given these results that our
null hypothesis
and if that probability is less than 5%
then we say it's more likely that the
hypothesis is your fault and we're able
to reject and that probability that the
null is true is called a female so there
are lots of different hypothesis tests
depending on what kind of patient
so there we can have different numbers
of hearings so we talked about a
technique that you can have a b c d e f
sv how does that variance watch that's
one option
and then the more so there are two types
of medicine you have categorical metrics
for any changing aspects a categorical
metrics are things where you can phrase
it as a yes/no so clicked or differently
purchased we didn't purchase or
different results on a survey like for
dinner
because he knew is it something where
there's actually a number so for
instance if we wanted to look at dollar
amount purchase or amount of time spent
on a website or you know number of likes
generally we actually only deal with the
categorical data so that's what I'm
going to work here but it is worth
knowing that you for have continuous
data your options for hypothesis testing
or two sample t-test in this tutoring
and there's multiple variants go to use
both ain't no which tells you whether or
not there is and then choose rank test
which tells you which of the variants
per second and the documentation on
table 7 Sify for example t-test and
stats bottle already know that two key
are really good and you'll be able to
read those but it's just very clear that
he wants you to run to be tested on
continuous variables it's much more
likely that you'll rather not
categorical variables in both cases you
can use chi-square and we're going to
kind of do that so let's go turn up-up
okay so the way we've run an a t-test is
we start our heart moving analyze maybe
test after run is we create something
called a contingency table and a
contingency to people should have it the
sum of all cells should describe all
people who participated in our test so
for instance this cell describes people
who saw Barry a and did not close the
cell you're just ready for some so very
obedient enough with the app this cell
described people is not very a did
clicking at and then be and did quite
beyond so it's important to remember
here is intuitively you might think that
row one should be like the whole twenty
number of people in testing room should
we be a number of people to play and
that's not right we should be mutually
exclusive cells so in this case what you
can see is the total number of people
suffering a was about the total number
sake so once we have that from psycho
dot stats we import hi to contingency
and that's the test we'll be using and
then we fit we create an umpire array
that represents our contingency table
and then all we do is we call Chi Chi
Chi contingency with our table that
we've created and then generally you
want to use correction equals false
correction is four we need to use
something called of one theory never
know how to pronounce it I'm for any
correction if we have a very small
number in any piece of Italy that is
less than five um but if you forget to
make sure that it doesn't make a really
huge difference in your evaluating
you're probably fine so there will be a
whole lot of things that comment that
that are returned by this function but
all you care about is that value which
tells you whether or not equal reaction
all hypotheses so we can fill in these
values for our contingency table so that
it matches here
and then we run this
okay so in this case our p-value is 0.3
so that's saying that there's a 30%
chance that our null hypothesis please
so we're not able to reject the null
hypothesis in this case so why might
that be what we look here we have a
sample size of thousand and you have a
click-through rate of five and six
percent as we saw from our kids before
and that's not really enough to be sure
we get the right answer but what are we
kept the proportions the same but just
our sample size is five times larger so
what I'm going to do in this case is
just copy this contingency table over
but I'm going to multiply everything by
five so I'm going to say that I somehow
was able to get five times as many
samples you can see here our p-value is
our 2% so if I had 5 times more samples
in the same result I would be able to
reject the null hypothesis so the other
thing that is worth knowing mostly or if
you are doing a job interview and
someone asked you what is the hypothesis
test or a because the proportional Z
test will also give you the same answer
as the chi-square and you can just prove
that right here really quickly and you
can see the exact same answer this is
for the original one
I think the chi-squared is better
because one people notice that it has
sort of newer arguments a little bit
easier and choose the chi-square you can
support multiple variants if you had
ABCD you could still use the chi-square
just take your a rating okay so that was
pretty straightforward but what do we do
when we actually get those results so
particular in that first game what does
it actually mean when my a t-test is
significant so it means that we don't
have enough evidence to reject the null
hypothesis but it doesn't necessarily
that our null hypothesis is there could
be a difference we're just not able to
detect now what's important is that we
are able to say is that there is a
difference it is smaller than southern
accent we're gonna in the next I talk
about how to actually know that accident
but which easy imperfect cannot pain up
if you're a B test is not to admit that
does not mean to just run your tests
longer and get more spam generally you
should be able to know the level of
sensitivity and getting more sensitivity
will not necessarily help your business
case the other thing that's also
important is as you learn more and more
details selectively test when you get an
answer what will eventually bias your
results so if you always are ready a
t-test until de groots
that's not a valid statistical technique
so it's important to decide the sample
size before you run your test and yeah
how would we do that conveniently there
are online calculators so you could play
around with that simulation tool that I
should be getting but why would you do
that then there's my calculator it's so
much easier so this is a really easy one
it's the Optimizely sample size
calculator and it has a whole bunch of
parameters shoulders are very different
from what we saw and say absolutely talk
about what these mean so the first thing
it asks you is a baseline conversion
rate so what that basically means is
what do we think the click-through rate
for a it's and remember as we noticed
before as this increases your necessary
sample size increases so let's set it at
5 let me have a war minimum detectable
affects people's heart this is how
sensitive we want our test
[Applause]
things up there making shameless plug
for doing all packing the design so
[Music]
today next door okay so minimums capable
of excise this is the difference between
a and B that you want to be able to
tackle so this is when we were playing
around here this is basically this do we
want to be able to detect when they're
with their water park or do you want
more sense of people if you want to be
able to detect a smaller difference
between a and B now what does this
twenty percent it is twenty percent
relative to this five percent so in this
case that this would be five percent
versus six percent up and so the way you
would do that is five times one right
here to figure out what it what it is
and then finally we have statistical
significance so that's just that we
wanted what keep out the organic juice
so I had said previously he is 0.05
that's kind of the standard that most
people use if this is not a particularly
important feature that your work here is
reveal to implement you might not want
to use profile at woodys point one and
vo he with the less Circuit of Europe of
your results if this is super important
it's going to cost you a billion dollars
to do your very probably muscles
more certain than for a five mile
service to make University but yet so we
can see and again here we can see as we
increase the minimum detectable event
our sample size goes down so what we see
here in this case if we wanted to tell
the difference between 5 & 6 we need a
sample size of about 6,500 so you'll
notice that we're actually evil in that
examples we've got significance at 5,000
that's fine that's as we happen to get
low right results in that this is saying
in order to be certain deepa that
there's going to be all sorts of
variance and we might not actually
observe 5% and 6% now let's talk a
little bit more about that minimum
detectable difference on base might
converge so base my conversion rate how
do we actually get the baseline
conversion rate so it variate a is your
existing property base is saying it is
control and then B is something I want
to change it's really easy we just use
some sort of historical data otherwise
you have some options to look and see if
there's a similar metric in your
existing product so for instance with
the example of the email marketing maybe
this is a totally new email campaign
that's out there and you don't have
durable data but you do have other email
marketing and say here's a similar one
it was a 1% click-through rate one can
use one percent or you can also look at
industry trends so again I'm just gonna
keep using emails because that's really
comment one you can google and say what
our typical email open rates for x thing
and yet just football just aren't one
and then if all those fails wild guesses
talk to your product manager talk to
other people at your company and come up
with a number that makes sense
remember that the smaller your baseline
rate is the the larger sample size
you're going to need to want to err on
the side of smaller TV for a certain
task angle size minimum detectable
difference this one's I panicked
so the best case for being able to take
a really good minimum detectable is when
you can tie everything to all so for
instance if you can say I know the
variant a dry product does it is very
key is some feature I want to build I
know that to build out the full feature
is going to cost this many dollars or
maybe very be is some ad that I want to
run and I know that it costs as much
money to run the ad then you can balance
that is okay this is you lift I would
need to see between a and B to justify a
console that's kind of your best-case
scenario it will actually put dollars
and say I mean exactly this look um the
example that we had when we were talking
about price points that's a great
example we can actually say this is the
technical name so for instance if you're
offering a 20% discount you need to have
them make more sales
now what about it did something fuzzier
than so for instance with our email with
email marketing it doesn't cost anything
to send to your branch
how do we how do we decide what I'm
going to Leventis um they're sure to it
one is we can say what's the smallest
difference I mean merit reporting to my
boss like for instance right they I
agree install a test the other thing
that folks will often do is they'll work
backwards they'll say I know that it's
reasonable for me to have 3000 in each
sample size so you'll do is you'll kind
of click around until we get this to be
3000 and you say okay I'll know that I
would be able to detect
roughly a 30 percent of mountains and
I'm going to be comfortable doing it
when I get my results back if I can't
reject the null hypothesis that it's
still possible that there is a less than
30 percent difference between the two
bearings
and it might get effect it is 30 percent
more free okay so let's let's try it so
if y'all can navigate to optimize Lingam
slash sample size calculator play around
with it for a while get a sense for how
it works and how Clifton the different
buttons changes links and we're going to
do that yeah we're going to do that or
let's get him give it three minutes yes
oh that's a really good really good
point notice that this is variation so
if it says 3000 that means you double
that and that's it you're doing a 50-50
split if you're doing another outlet
this is the smaller sample size you
would actually exact that is an
excellent question time and performance
so there is no rule of thumb erratically
you're a t-test could run for a minute
however the longer you run it the war
other variables you're going to creep it
so the classic example of this is
suppose you're running an a/b test and
you find out that you're you know some
other department and your company is is
making some big change to the website
that's probably not good tailing that
happened in the middle of your a t-test
cuz you've not changed the initials or
someone else is running a sale and send
out a huge email last night that's also
not good so generally you want to try to
get your a B test done you know within a
couple of weeks
test and nose the patient was talk to
you before so that's when we go back to
the sanity checks which really work at
someone who's in charge of a t-test and
can do that coordination or Crossman
episodes everyone feels pretty good with
using the optimize this a makes pretty
good sense all right so the final tank
that I want it to touch off and then
move your questions in how many know
were in the talkable for this on
statistics yeah and you guys all heard a
lot about Bayesian statistics right yeah
okay this whole thing that we're doing
is frequentist and they'll probably
heard that frequent just as bad Bayesian
is good so why are we doing a pretty
much estimate
so the main reason is that it only makes
sense we have a strong Breyer and the
whole point of our a t-test is that we
don't have a priori don't know any
information about which of these
variants are better that's why we're
running because now there is a patient
version of a new test it has to do with
that time so if you have a very specific
situation where you know that you have
sort of been infinite all those panel
sizes so there's no sort of oh I only
had this many people or mushrooms
there's actually just your whole
customer base for ever's is never going
to have trouble getting it out and you
really need to get you the right answer
as quickly as possible then you actually
have a Beijing situation because you
update your prior a smoker and it's
called a multi on Vanderburgh the reason
it's called most romantic is that you
know the like slot machines in a casino
those are called one-armed bandits
apparently I involved and the imaginary
situation where people came up with the
statistics is suppose you have a whole
bunch of slot machines and you know that
one of them has a better payoff for the
others you want to the situation is you
want to be trying all the machines to
try to find out which one's the best
payout but as quickly as possible you
want to stop pulling the machines that
you don't have their payouts and only
pull the one that has good apparent so
what you're able to do is in a Bayesian
sense as you pull each time and get a
result either yes
did you update your prior and that will
let you zero in on a right answer much
faster so in order to run multi-armed
bandit you have to have a special test
setup probably a custom one being built
yourself that probably only makes sense
if you're going to be running a lot of
these so for instance the speed is
obviously going to have a multi-armed
bandit set up these be watching very
quickly zero in on correct title for
each for each of their articles whereas
most people that's just a lot less
important because they are you generally
actually most places I've worked for
having limited number of the limited
sample size they're one but they don't
have the truly big sample size they need
for a multi-armed bandit it's usually
much more cases like well we're going to
run this or we can see what results we
get and then the others you shouldn't
you have to it's a big investment to set
up this system that is the end of my
prepared material I guess I would like
to take questions unbend and testing
would you agree that it makes sense to
use it maybe if you're very loss averse
loss averse service yes 8:08 the
question when should you use multi-armed
bandit doesn't based on your very la
servers yes if you think there's a very
high cost to having the wrong answer
Venable term and it is a great approach
so for instance pricey it makes a lot of
other questions yes so how can you
recommend a friend one through ten one
is no way
yes they tend to do that as continuously
we tend to pin it as Pat gasps techno
that that is a great question so the
question was for an NPS hat question
when we say on a scale of one to ten how
likely are you to recommend this product
you treat it as continuous or as bins so
from NPS specifically we tend to analyze
it as bins so the standard and case for
is and nine and a ten is a promoter a
seven or an eight is a neutral and a 1
through 6 is a tractor and that the net
promoter score is defined as these
promoters the percent of voters rights
protection tractors what I have
generally done is do as prevails and and
treat it as sorry sir as two-bit and
read it first is that as category there
we go look you but if you just happen to
have a ten-point scale it wasn't NPS
specifically and thought that your
distribution was going so the other
thing about NPS is it really tends to be
a very quiet little distribution that's
why it's analyzed that right these
people and either shake hands or 0 they
tend not to say a lot of things in the
middle if you have something that's a
smoother distribution like that so for
instance if you go by point like a bike
scale for an a3 disagree with statement
then it might make more sense to treat
it as newest and to treat it as the
average a rule of thumb you can uses
will you be recording a percent or we'd
be recording an average for that
question so generally for MPs reporting
representing respect this percent of
people are covers per second people are
detractors
whereas for a five-point Likert scale
each relatively common to report an
average to say people on average are a
three point set on this question any
other
yeah actually a setting where you have
too much surprise often the question
becomes how long you threatening all
right and I think that it's a sacrifice
when students I want lots feeling while
it's the eighties when you play yes to
the proper that's a good present so when
you say clients is it like you're you're
80 test me oh no marking so as I push
yeah so so question was generally how do
we think about late for these what I
would say is always go back what is the
decision so it's so if the decision
you're trying to make is which act
should I run and you have some sense of
sort of how important this is you can
get a sense of like is this something
where it's more important to have a
asked answer that's less accurate or is
this something where it's like a really
important I can't make it really I need
to wait if you just want to run it
quickly what I would say is do that sort
of backward sample size thing where
rather rather than saying what sample
size do I need say this is the sample
size I think I can get in the timeframe
you're interested in and then report
back this is the effects that I will be
able to to detect and again a lot of
times you can sort of freeze that is all
in paint or dollars of some sort you can
say like okay I I would be able to
detect it this ad is twenty percent back
that we know that of the movement on the
ad this percent will make a purchase a
purchases of approximately this those
you can put it in terms of dollars and
what will oftentimes happen fuel sheriff
or it might raise because you'll share
that with a client or of my team
internally and they'll say yeah that's
fine or they'll say oh wow actually what
to be able to attack something follow
that I'm feeling to give you more time
to run this but yeah oh look my my
experience generally has been that
people are more sensitive rather have a
less precise answer in shorter time than
a more precise answer and it's really
important to I think to try and put in
dollar values because the other screens
iPad is that a lot of times the person
who's asking about the test is violating
that first rule baby custom that they
really are transmitted shouldn't really
try to improve their it is better and so
they'll start out I think will either be
able to check any difference because I
want to be able to tell my bus how much
better my variance is that's original
one and you'll go through be like okay
well in that case you need you know
sixty thousand people and then they'll
say and then you're sort of asking okay
sir we can walk them back to a realistic
number I really do like the phrasing of
what is the difference thing you can
report to your boss and I feel stupid
because that does tend to get old you
stop thinking of it in terms of like I
want to be able to check any possible
difference I want to love the test as
long as possible if they weren't right
ya know it's not worth it what I would
say in that case so there's a couple
things it gets you really small and
you're able to I believe actually say
that qualitative feedback is more
helpful so either read a couple of books
on how to run focus groups and ramiro or
hire UX researcher I found that focus
groups actually extremely helpful
another thing if it's like an aesthetic
change to the website of recording equal
sessions and see where they read it can
be really helpful but only yeah just
talking to people running interview
he's better you're going to have that
small sample size I love the simulate
show the thing that I ran at the Yeti
where we have that will launch a
simulation that's mostly just for you to
develop an intuition about I like dogs
[Applause]